>> Tucker: FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ADVISOR GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS
ALREADY PLEADY GUILTY.
HE SAID HE WAS FRAMED.
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS JOINS US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
I SHOULD NOTE AT THE OUTSET
DESPITE HAVING YOUR LIFE TURNED
UPDATES  -- UPSIDEDOWN, THERE IS
NO EVIDENCE YOU SPIED FOR
RUSSIAN.
YOU MET HAVE A PROFESSOR.
WHERE IS THIS MAN TODAY?
>> THANKS FOR HOSTING ME,
TUCKER.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT PERSON
IN THIS INVESTIGATION.
THIS PROFESSOR IS ALLEGEDLY A
RUSSIAN AGENT WHO HAD
INFORMATION THAT THE RUSSIANS
POSSESSED HILLARY CLINTON EMAILS
WHICH HE PASSED ALONG TO ME.
NEW INFORMATION HAS COME OUT
RECENTLY FROM THIS MAN'S LAWYER.
WHAT HIS LAWYER IS TELLING THE
WORLD IS THAT THIS PERSON,
JOSEPH, YOU NOT WORKING FOR
RUSSIA WHEN HE WAS INTERACTING
WITH GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS AND THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
HE WAS THE UNDER THE GUIDANCE OF
THE FBI.
THIS INFORMATION IF IT'S TRUE
AND THERE IS NO REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT HIS LAWYER IS
SLANDERING HIS CLIENT, IF IT IS
TRUE, THIS INFORMATION ALONE
UPENDS THIS ENTIRE INVESTIGATION
IN MY EYES.
AND THE NARRATIVE OF ANY RUSSIAN
CONSPIRACY.
>> Tucker: THAT'S FOR SURE.
NOW I WISH WE HAD AN HOUR TO
TALK.
WE HAVE ABOUT 45 SECONDS.
WHERE IS THIS GUY?
WHY ISN'T HE ON CAPITOL HILL
EXPLAINING HIMSELF?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I DID NOT
RECEIVE CERTAIN EVIDENCE THAT IF
I HAD THAT INFORMATION
BEFOREHAND I WOULD NOT HAVE PLED
GUILTY.
THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE.
THIS PERSON IS HIDING SOMEWHERE
IN EUROPE ACCORDING TO HIS
LAWYER.
HE IS REPRESENTED BY A TOP LAW
FIRM IN LONDON DEALING WITH HIS
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE SPECIAL.
COUNSEL.
HE WILL COME OUT AFTER THE
INVESTIGATION IS OVER.